[Music]
james
is with us in san diego hi james welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hey guys how are you guys doing great
how can we help
hey thank you for taking the call yeah
i'm relatively new
to uh to the family i started binge
watching
all of your shows since covet happened
um so i'm trying to identify
kind of where i would stand and
everything um
we have a baby coming in in march
yeah welcome welcome to the family by
the way
thank you thank you we got married
january last year
and uh recently in the middle of covet
moved from new york city to california
started a new
job as a children's pastor here um
and pretty much i'm just trying to
identify what priorities should be
obviously i know we need to save for the
baby um we're on
baby step one currently well actually
baby step two
because we have a thousand but we do
have
um a loan a car loan we bought a second
um second-hand car when we got here um
so it wasn't new but it was definitely i
still took out an 18 000
loan for it um and i guess i'm just
trying to figure out okay what priority
should i be
focusing on between now and
i guess next year really yeah and the
baby
well a rule of thumb james is the fact
that you guys are expecting a baby
things shift a little bit here so we
usually always say you're gazelle
intense you're paying off your debt
that's where you guys would be
but because the baby is coming we're
actually gonna pause baby step two and
just pile up money
because you guys just have that thousand
dollar in savings and so just anything
you'd be paying at the
at the debt you want to stay current on
all of your debt but not paying extra on
it
and pile up some savings and then once
baby comes and mom and baby are safe
and good to go then you can apply all
that money besides the thousand dollars
onto your debt so how much debt do you
guys have you have the eighteen thousand
dollar car loan
just the eighteen yeah that's right okay
yeah we do have
a little bit on some cards from this
month but it will be paid off
um tomorrow when i get paid okay so
we're going to tell you and then um
tonight tonight we're going to teach you
to have a thing called plastic surgery
where you chop up the cards and get on a
debit card system where you quit
you quit spending money you don't have
and yeah jump onto
uh every dollar or jump into ramsey plus
and start the free trial
and get the every dollar budgeting app
and it'll help you put together your
budget where you can
make your money behave monthly that way
and so what is your household income
right now
uh we're on 70 000 okay so if you were
to just guess because you haven't done
your budget i can tell
which is fine you're just just joining
the family but uh
if you were to guess how much money a
month
can you pile up if you don't pay any
extra on debt
and your only goal was to build your
savings
um well actually i've done a brief
budget i think at currently we have
about a thousand dollars excess
a month um from every
yep paying off all the bills the
necessary bills and then they're
alone and when's the baby come james
march march okay
yeah and i had one more thing my mom so
i i
also came into an inheritance this year
um my late uncle passed and
i was in his will so he got 19 000 from
that i
obviously tied the tides off of that and
then but my mom's been giving me money
uh two times
like five thousand dollars every couple
months to go towards that down payment
but she
said specifically she wanted that for
that do i just leave that there until
we're at a place to use that or
that's fine just set it over a separate
savings account and just pretend like
it's not there
because she's you know she stipulated
how that gets to be used so we have to
honor that
um not what i normally would do don't
care for that idea but it's okay you're
there
now so so you have 19 000 and i'm gonna
tell you that when you really start
leaning in on your budget and you and
your wife are working on it really
really tight
and you get you get more intense and
more focused you're gonna do more than a
thousand
let's pretend for example purposes for
five months
between now and march you did two
thousand
well that would be ten thousand dollars
you already have nineteen
so that would put you at twenty nine
thousand dollars in savings when baby
comes
i actually have twenty six currently in
the
in the housing one no i'm talking about
the housing
the housing's separate yeah wait is the
inheritance for the house
the inheritance i put into the housing
one no
um no your inheritance is getting ready
to pay your car off after baby comes
okay so okay at the moment it's older
than the same one but i i yeah
i would have only your mom's money in
the house fund
gotcha because that's the money that she
has dictated the give
what the gift is for the inheritance
money is yours to do with as you please
yeah and so what we're gonna have is
we're gonna have your inheritance money
house money separate from mom your
inheritance money plus whatever you can
save between now and baby so you're
gonna have 25 to 30
000 in that account when the baby comes
that's gonna feel pretty good isn't it
yeah yeah a lot of comfort with a new
baby a new job in a new land called
california
and a new marriage and all this stuff so
there's a lot of money here to give you
comfort
for a short period of time anyway now
baby comes home mama comes home
we write a check and pay off the car
that's going to leave you somewhere in
the neighborhood of ten thousand dollars
yes sir for your baby step three
emergency fund and so then you can start
to save
in addition to that towards your home if
you want to we call that baby step 3b
and that's how we would execute the baby
step plans
in your situation so but rachel's
exactly right
excuse me what we've got to do is you
push pause
on your baby steps you do not do the
baby steps when the baby's on the way or
when you've got
some other thing that's on the horizon
that's a big deal like you know you're
going to lose your job in two months
they've announced it
yep you know you push pause and you pile
up cash
to get ready for that then when you get
the other side of the situation
like baby comes or you get the new job
or whatever then you clean out the
account all the way down to a thousand
in your case you're not gonna need to
clean it all the way out because you're
gonna have
more and you're probably gonna have
almost have your baby step three
completed
it's very cool you're in a really good
position yeah and i think some people
who are new to the program
because i know like he said like during
quarantine a lot of people just
binge watch youtube and stuff but even
though the money is in the account even
just from the inheritance
and he has enough money to pay off the
car today you still press pause
because of the big life event so even
though it's there still press pause
it'll be fine stay current on the car
and then again in a few months in march
they can pay it off yeah
and just just because the last thing you
want to do is have
eight thousand dollars in your account
and baby comes
and you have a nine thousand dollar
issue yeah
and then you gotta worry about money and
baby that's right that's right our
money and mommy and so we don't we just
don't need that this is supposed to be a
blessed time an exciting time a
fun time and when you take money stress
off the table it allows that to occur
that way the joy can flow
i'm not worried about anything else so
fun first babies are so fun